for the past four years I think I always
come back to Stanford and Jack McDonough
well my professors back at GSB asked me
come back and talk about Internet and
the startups and sometimes about
investment for the past four years and
this year's the first year I I haven't
made it to his class so I decided to
come back here to do the similar the
same thing when I was preparing for this
keynote I realized that roughly about 11
years ago I was back at GSB on the same
podium with Jack Ma so I was thinking I
was in the public eyes of the holidays
and I was thinking hopefully this time
were not at peak of another internet
bubble but today I want to talk about
the variance story and and we'll talk
about the how we innovate at the what we
called the bleeding edge of solo mo and
solo mo is coined by John doar and his
partner Mary Meeker when she was still
working on more incidentally I think she
came out with an Internet report every
year which a lot of your read and and
ever since that the invented this world
has been widely used by by the startup
guys in the industry I mean social local
and the mobile I want to talk about
social first so what are you so sure a
lot of people here use Facebook Twitter
and a lot of you probably use reading as
well if you're back in China and the
social has really been around for a long
time I remember back in 99 I started my
first startup China in it was actually a
first generation social network with
real names except back in those days
there were no photographs Turin is what
difficult to take digital photos and
upload so we really call it nowadays the
at that time was the face book without
face
and so social network has been around
for a long time at least you know 699
and and now that they have transformed
industry to the certain extent that it's
almost becoming a spec which I'll
probably say potentially bigger then
search it's really one-dimensional ways
organizing the entire internet and user
behavior on the Internet
based on the personal relationships and
a person as the organizing Center versus
search is trying to organize entire
internet based on keywords so these are
the two very important transportation
infrastructure for the entire internet
and I really everybody else simply ride
on top of it so social as we were
talking
providing one additional way of
transporting activities users over the
internet using the social graph and
that's the fundamental innovation we
believe that social properties whelmed
most important product DNA's I've
invented on the Internet
and there will be continuous new
innovations but I think fundamental
innovations like these probably will be
very hard to come by I know I talk about
social the implications of that but
before I I want to talk a little bit
about rinrin and and ever since 1999 the
social has moved has has has swift China
and sparring a lot of little companies
and services a lot of a lot of different
vertical sectors you will see that rigor
and showed up quite a few places here as
we are in different segments of the
social and give you a few stats for some
of you were interested in China Internet
as the the user base now is close to
half a billion 500 million users and of
those 500 million users there they're
about 300 million users who have used a
blog and that's where a large
there was us roughly about 200 million
people have used the twitter-like
service called a way boy in Chinese and
there's about 220 million users who have
used social network and remember that
has about 130 million activated user
base in China out of that 220 so I won't
talk about how how we do social
networking in China and as some of you
might know that the China internet
environment is very different from here
in the US in the sense that the the use
of segments mostly young and and a lot
of them live in second here and
assertive cities and and they demand a
lot of entry individual individual
attention to the presentation to the
Internet services they have so this is
the first thing we did we allow users on
a paying basis to customize their pages
we also give them different means to you
know to beautify the page such as
personalizing the pointer the cursor as
well so picking different skiing's and
we we even have a partnership with
Disney to to sell that at a service
based on Disney characters and another
example is the radiant desktop desktop
is something that you know that the
desktop applications in China is
extremely important the most valuable in
terms of market cap internet company in
China is called Tencent QQ it's
essentially a desktop software company
was a QQ instant messenger as the
flagship for the entire Suites of
Internet services and also well I'm the
largest revenue category is internet
games also is based on desktops PCs so
we we have developed rare and desktop is
really a desktop software that's
internet connected that does two things
one is that he allows you
to view their to view their newsfeed in
real-time and allowed them to reply to
her in real-time
also allowing them to chat this Prada is
widely used by our active users
particularly those uses on college
campus and is something you session and
many of you know that China has
traditionally being agriculture based
country for the past few thousand years
and so it's probably not surprising that
the first farming game was launched on
women in China even before farmville was
launched here this game is called happy
farming was so successful in 2009 that
it created a sensation in China for some
reason they invented a game mechanic
that's worried where unique is calling
stealing vegetables that became very
popular I mean in US this on Facebook
there's a poke right but in China people
are not used to poking each other but
they're like stealing vegetables so in
2009 the this game was so hot that you
have fairy tales of grandma getting up
in the morning 3 o'clock harvesting
their vegetables and then stealing their
neighbor's vegetables online and and so
that's another Chinese characteristic of
the internet how it evolves and showing
another example in in in the field of a
social content this is a vertical social
Q&A that we launched long ago it's the
first was first automobile so she
couldn't a it allows you to to ask any
questions related to the car and we
promised them to promise me answer the
question within 24 hours by a real
expert that's where a fight so this is
our answer to social count and we think
that because before social networking
can you age most of the web services
websites as content based optimize
themselves for search engine but
nowadays increasingly social network
drive
increasing amount of traffic who decides
so we're seeing that you know these web
services needs to fundamentally change
the planet DNA said they both what we
search engine as well as working with
social networks so this is one example
of where well build product that that
cater to you how social networks would
like the content side work and a lot of
people debated about open versus closed
integrated approach versus distributed
approach for example back in the PC era
Microsoft succeeded by dominating the
software layer and and and and opening
up the the hardware layer to Arab Leo's
to participate and they took the market
away from integrated approach of Apple
but in a post PC era the same approach
of integrated services pioneered by
Apple went over Microsoft so we are
experimenting different approaches of
open and integrated you know to serve
consumers best for example in areas of
social gaming we're totally open but
this is one example that we offer a
highly integrated closed music service
for the one simple reason
we want to work with third parties to
provide music service that your users
but nobody could afford copyrighted
content nobody could afford that because
if you cannot guarantee a minimal amount
of distribution you're now gonna spend a
lot of money buying the copyrights so we
went ahead with bar the entire available
copyrights and we start offer integrated
social music to a user base and I
believe this is most likely where
Facebook will end up doing but we're
doing that first and this is why example
random radio where you can listen to the
radio with your friends and sharing your
music text I'm gonna give you another
example of what we call social
accounting not long ago we launched
various shells and which is really what
we call light block which were similar
to tumblr here it allow a user to
publish social accountant to highly
customized very simple user interface
that can be subscribed by anybody on
reran so we after we opened up the
service he instantly became the boy in
China because we have so many uses
what who have special interest you know
one is shared the expertise the interest
was with the entire user base of area in
addition of maintaining a closed
personal profile on a room finally I
want to talk a little bit on the variant
part about how we monetize and why it's
different from other social networks in
the world last year majority of revenue
of a revenue came from gaming I really
know that let's say on Facebook most of
revenue came from advertising well
similar to that in the sense that a
larger part of Facebook advertising
actually come from social gaming vendors
that try to promote their services on
Facebook
so we're similar in that but what's
different is that nowadays with deriving
one-half of revenue from brand
advertisers these are brand advertisers
who wants to found with our user base
and build a brand on area and so far we
have what close to 1,000 advertisers in
China this includes some of the biggest
multinationals and local brands and I
predict that even now we mostly in
advertising I predict that in three
years later one 1/2 of revenue will be
coming from e-commerce now let me move
to the second dimension of Sonoma which
is local for
for many people local mean different
things but for us it means two things
while it means location the other means
local commerce well you can generalize
that as e-commerce so last year
recognizing the the Makah trend of
Commerce ecommerce becoming social we
launched a social buying buying service
corn or me which in Chinese means sticky
rice and it became a railway success
that I would talk about later and in
addition to your offering group I also
offer local coupons
imagine using Iranian phone product and
and you'll be browsing these coupons and
a group deals based on a map and you can
take instant actions based on how close
you are and haha JIRA for example at 12
o'clock we're primarily showing you know
ramen shops within 5 minute walking
distance from where you are a salon so
you are moving and how we integrate is
the commerce with social network of
course is by newsfeed
when a user buys a group by purchase or
clicked on a coupon and liked it and
what America sends the news feed out and
when the friends see it they will click
on it and take action on it and it
becomes viral and let me show you how
this very fast and Kure commercial
miracles this is the first deal ever
I'll know me when we launched it in June
last year it's it's a movie theater in
suburban Beijing with multiple screens
and built by the famed movie star Jackie
Chan let's go Jackie Chan theater
I don't assume Beijing and and because
those theaters are so far away that even
the owner tries to lure the users the
consumers by promising free Mercedes
ride this still couldn't feel the
squeaks the shelters for for like years
and then on that day they decided to you
know give a try with us even though
we're brandy we we had no brand but we
only had one thing we had we had
newsfeed integration with regret so
wheezing the first 12 hours launching
the deal starting from them midnight by
noon we have sold 70,000 tickets only
rent alone
so we're basically selling only to the
or user base in Beijing because remember
that's only for one movie theater and
these white-collar workers was so happy
with that deal because that that that
deal came were deep discount typically
sold for $20 plus for two tickets but we
were selling that at $6 $7 for two
person plus the ice cream and popcorn -
so these consumers are so happy they go
out to lunch and talk about it and
talking about a second propagation of
viral right so so their colleagues you
know once hearing upon that decided to
also participate so after lunch we sold
another 230,000 for a total of a 300,000
tickets for one movie theater in one day
with no advertising that's the power of
Commerce coupled with social network and
lastly I want to talk about the mobile
aspect of salomo
and for us Mobile is really a fusion
between social and local right because
mobile device is convenient device that
both offers mobility as well as uniquely
the locational information but in order
to do well on mobile and and and take
full advantage of a locational
information that it has to offer that's
another advantage of real name based
social networking
offers that people feel much more
comfortable sharing their location with
their true friends and as well I'm the
reason we're in is the number one
location based a service provider in
China and our usage has shoot off the
chart ever since we launched it and so
if our competitors still hasn't launched
their service probably intimidating by
the advanced features that we offer
we're also the first social network in
the world to offer to allow our users to
combine the usually sees the created on
a mobile phone with the location so
instead of doing a very simple checking
service we allow users to update their
status at a certain location and ensure
that so that's that's like generating a
sentence not just with you know a key a
key mint key sentence but also with some
descriptions attached to it we also
allow users to to upload the picture
with the comment was a location or
service with the location information
and share it with their friends and
that's the power of real name based
social network and also the power of the
integrated nature of our services if
this location-based service is is
provided by a third party then it's
worth difficult to integrate the kind of
service for instance if you click and
the use or a mobile service and you
click the you know the location-based
buttons and you get the older nearby
deals going arm and and where your
friends are nearby so on and so forth
so I want to show how powerful it can be
with local combining social local and
mobile this is a real case we we offer a
location-based service integrated
campaign for master cow which is a
leading which is a leading Easter noodle
and drink brand
China in one the city sent into your
city for the Herve it's a college town
and when our users logging onto the
mobile phone in that city or even entire
China they will be able to participate
in this events if we outside the city
you can participate online on the PC or
if you're there you can go to the store
and the checking and this campaign
bodying six thousand new consumers into
the store to try out that drinks in one
city and that's probably the first time
in the world experiment at least in
China experiment like this happens
mobile commerce really generates brand
new marketing opportunities for
businesses and the comesss and this
shows how viral it can be and finally
some concluding remark the reason I use
bleeding I want to use cutting edge
right but some of you might know the
internet industry is so competitive in
China I decided to use bleeding so what
is about about salomo first of all we
think that mobile will change everything
it's a new computing platform was the
importance that's even probably higher
importance than the the the conventional
PC remember every time when there's a
computing platform shift for trains
change hands fortunes were destroyed and
created old company big company got
destroyed and new company erupted we
think there's going to be huge creation
and destruction of wealth in the in the
TMT sector in the next five years and we
probably already seen some of those
right we have seen we have heard and use
of many companies decided to sell
themselves or a spinoff
their PC divisions or selling themselves
entirely to Google
remember these are companies just five
years ago was almost looking invincible
so we think that this the entire TMD
space will be transformed because the
newer generation of leaders such as
Apple Google Facebook they're so
innovative and and they're taking such a
dramatic business approach that I think
that the new round of battle would be
were worried fierce but for consumers is
a great show because we benefit we all
benefit from the intense competition of
these highly innovative where a
humongous companies and all major
Internet services will be transformed I
sure I have shown some of the services
in such example of chilling calm a
scarce calm right which is entirely
social right it's not worry
surging you're friendly it doesn't allow
surging your search we decide to just
let it fully integrate with Riaan and
only take advantage of social network of
the four categories of services online
commerce entertainment that means gaming
and video content and the communication
search historically only a factor to
which is a content search fundamentally
transformed content business and became
the Camping's in content they also
helped facilitate the rise of e-commerce
you can search help ecommerce to derive
demands and and the generate leads but
if you look at social social is one
category is such a fundamental
infrastructure that it transform almost
all the categories of the four right you
look at social by itself is
communication they transform
communication it diplays email its de
placing email Instant Messenger and
these first generation companies new
services and becoming bigger and it's
transforming the content distribution
because I use Marian
every day I found myself no longer using
news portals because I call off and
these are very already my friends share
those news if it matters to them it
matters to me and I found myself using
Lance of search as well particularly on
mobile phones I seldom search on mobile
I don't feel the need because just by
accessing rear end I get most of the
content that I feel like I need it and
gaming is another area that's
transformed right we you know we saw the
rise of Zynga and and Playfish and these
companies they started from zero to
multi-billion dollar value in a matter
of one or two years the same amount you
know it's the same amount of value that
took EA
and vivendi that case of time to build
so with the rise of socio and and the
cutting edge competition of these highly
innovative companies we think that our
life will be be fundamentally changed
the whole will be closer connected the
commerce entertainment content
communication will be permanently shaved
transformed into better and better
services that's more accessible
providing more value to consumers and
anarion being a key player in a solo
mode and a social revolution in China we
feel privileged in the meantime we feel
we're standing and the bleeding bleeding
edge because competition and because
innovation but we're we're very
confident that was the continuous
innovation and and the tireless effort
one day we're gonna build
we're gonna build a services that will
serve every Chinese in any way they can
imagine and thank you you can find me on
rear end by certainly my name sure
and yeah I'm I would like to answer any
question they might have the microphones
here in the aisle please and identify
yourself there's a microphone there
thank you Joe thank you everybody I was
working in a search engine company in
China and I was about asking to your
question about the how do you think
about the future competition between the
search energy and the social networking
because the in the previous age that's
age of search such Google and the battle
in China and now the social come up and
there is a fierce competition between
Facebook and Google in US and how do you
think app I do and in China competition
thank you as a word good question I
think I alluded it's you sound that in
my speech but I think that's where the
classroom I think the old school
thinking about how social networks
compete with search was worried
traditional they say oh they worry about
Facebook or area and creating a search a
social search or the way to compete was
then for searching needs to create
social search on a search platform but
that was deadly wrong because the way
that social now will compete with search
is natural search is true newsfeed
newsfeed is the main way is the main
mechanism for social network to
transport content and information and
the search I mean a search action is the
main way for for search to work right so
therefore the way they compete is is
really social network created a turreted
way for people to obtain information
that's relevant for them it indirectly
reduces the number of curious on search
because people are
radish would have found out what I want
to know but more importantly they
indirectly reduce the consumption are
other forms of media including these
photos I mean that that's that's why
Yahoo nowadays is entering a difficult
time because their main portal business
simply hurt and the mail the email
visitor which used to be the anchoring
asset for Yahoo is now impacted by
Facebook too so so that's when I think
about III I wasn't think that the you
know if one day Facebook is exceeded
Google or very excited by the as none
it's not because we came out with a way
to search only because that our user
base has grown so big and the console a
bigger percentage of the daily content
including what we called absolute
content the content that's not generated
by the friends by the content generated
by not by their friends but by some
publishers once they have once you
reached a critical mass the usage of
search would drop and and that that's
that's really how the competition place
on that's question yeah just from your
presentation I saw a lot of like
applications actually are owned or
partially owned by Union that's quite
different in us because we see like
Twitter and Facebook are quite open and
purely open platform so they open the
interface to integrate the third-party
applications more than the platform in
China so why you think I mean China
social network platform choose a
different approach in term of this like
strategy for third-party applications
thank you well good question I think
there's no right or wrong
I think the same example plays out here
in USA use example Microsoft versus
versus Apple Apple took integrated close
approach but managed offer unparalleled
use experience by integrating by
optimizing or crossing different stats
and by making the making the technical
compromises and and and and and an to to
to make to deliver integrated
high-performance to consumers and your
case we are well philosophy is always
open we only do those verticals such as
music that that no third parties can do
well and another example will be
location-based service
no cert of hotties can do really well
I'll ask you putting a lot of money and
of course most of the certified
companies doesn't have a lot of
financial resource so unless they see
something they can guarantee the success
they're not going to throw in the
financial resources the engineering is
supposed to do it
so for us we decided to focus on a very
few verticals where it's worth difficult
and impossible for certain policy to do
but we opened up the rational platform
for everybody to participate such as
gaming such as all the vertical
applications including including the
file sharing including you know whole
bunch of other services so so we think
that there's no right around with open
or closed
what's absolute right around it's all
about consumers will do whatever
consumer demands and we'll do our best
to deliver the best the service is
available for them being closed or open
yes so this is changing I'm also a stem
for alumni and a very royal user of
since 2005 so I want to ask more about a
user expending strategy outside of the
ecology student because from my own
experience like impose on Raymond and
Facebook
I just noticed these days when I log in
Linden I'm still talking to my college
arm life and it's really just about
photo sharing they need news and even
game sometimes and Facebook is just
expending far more beyond that
and I was very successful in terms of
persuading my boss also lots of senior
people to join Facebook that's very hard
to persuade even like my mom to use
written and because she was like you can
just send me photos to take you so I
know we have just changed the name from
shall Nigerian and just want to learn
more about strategy around that thank
you yeah so I think in China right well
in your particular case I guess that's
probably because you have moved to
States and you develop most your my
color relationship here in states where
you kept your college buddies in China
so that's your case is probably a little
bit unique but in China or or you know
or about half of the user base is still
there college kids and then maybe
tempers in high school and the rest of
they're not white color we we are
worried you know penetration rating
white collar maca still were small so
that's where we see most girls gonna
come from and the way we do that the way
we increase from penetration
white-collar I think that I mean stem
from one mission which is really
offering the communication service
really well because we look at our core
offerings right is the the the the core
for rear end is communication photo
sharing is communication sharing an
article is communication and talking
each other's communication and sending a
photo is communication so anything does
relate to communication we want to do it
really really well and so far because
we're such a young company so compared
with other companies that's been around
for like 10-15 years or a number of
Engineers like 10% of theirs so so I
think that we're gonna continue to
investing engineering forces and hiring
the vast talents and and leverage on
those talents to build the best the next
generation communication services
because we think communication is key we
think that for white-collar in China
that they it's a little different from
hearing us where we're typically a
white-collar work at the young graduated
go to big city the salaries not
hi and and they they're the you know
their status their dear the sense of
insecurity is much bigger than typical
their counterparts in the US so we need
to help them defend who means which
means help them to deal with you know
job changes and and as well as finding
them helping them finding the Bastille
to get the biggest bang for the buck
because their salary cannot cope with
the inflation in big cities so we need
to find a value for them and and also
you increase the value of their
communication time span our area and
basically helping them to do well in
offline life but also giving them more
value for the every hour of time span
our area so that's what general strategy
next one yeah this gentleman I'm DK to a
visitor I have two questions the first
one it's a referring to Professor Duncan
said some of the Internet services it's
struggled in China and I think that's
probably more true for some of American
companies who are trying to establish a
foothold in their they are struggling
more than Chinese so the question is
what is this really the root problem of
the struggling especially for American
companies and my second question is in
some way related to this that's also a
profit Syntagma referred to yesterday
there was a big sell-off of all the
Chinese Internet service the triggering
was at least if you read a paper says
that Justice Department is a going to
open investigation all these Chinese
Internet services now why did the
Chinese Internet services are so
vulnerable to this factual or rumored
things are the two questions related why
Americans find so hard to survive and in
some
way that it did America now view the
Chinese company with some kind of
suspicion interesting question um I
think I think that the for the first
question how international companies do
in China I think that my observation is
that traditional multinational companies
do extremely well in China these
companies includes
you know KFC KFC is one of the biggest
Jim you know restaurants in China they
do so well even though fried chicken is
not traditional part of Chinese diet now
their whole changed and I remember
caterpillar owns a huge building in
Beijing right adds to Microsoft
so these traditional multinational
companies doing extremely well in China
relative to the technology companies
well I think the size of that is twofold
one then this probably related to your
second question the first reason
probably has something to do is the fact
that I mentioned earlier which is in our
industry we are going through a platform
change we're going is through the post
PC era into mobile computing era and
during this transition nobody has an
easy life including Apple even though
they are leading right they cannot
afford to slow down a little bit so I
think that that the reason that
technology company to not to do well as
well as their traditional counterparts
is probably has something to do with the
fundamental changes they have to do is
called colonization globalization but
the more important issues really how do
they deal with technology transformation
and a second reason is is has something
to you it was the the regulate reviewed
and that Internet is it's more like
related to media versus technology right
so in the in the in the regulator's view
we are more like a media company
we show we should be regulated as a
media company and a media company mostly
state control in China so so as to why
when when Cena went public more than ten
years ago
they invented a legal structure called
VI e were able interest you know awkward
you know entities to to basically to to
have a legal framework allowing them to
be listed in US and now what in ten
years later this can't do question again
I think you guys should ask Jack about
that if he's here
I heard he's coming here so so I'm not
actually on that but I guess Jack is the
single handedly you know calling
attention to this issue so so so reasons
later mark has been wearable at all for
Chinese Internet companies some of them
went down 18 percent in one day but you
know we're not worried we announced the
stock buyback yesterday and we we're
here for the long term we think any
ambiguities will be cleared out soon or
later and and the most important thing
is that is to focus on innovation and
and and and and you know and and think
about how to position yourself and and
combine innovate and grow the company so
if as long as you do that and taking
given fundamentals these you know these
marketer miles tend to work themselves
out because it's really difficult to
make a wave that shouldn't be there for
the long term I mean that at the end of
the day I would say the market the
market is is a voting machine in the
short term but as a as a it's a waiting
wishing the long term so I think my time
is up and thank you very much should be
here my pleasure to be here to you thank
you